from july to december this year italy is
the President of the Council of the
European Union this is the home of the
28 governments of the EU here ministers
diplomats and civil servants meet every
day to find a compromise on each single
law the EU producers and what does the
president of this council do the
presidency makes it happen
ambassador sannino is the Italian
permanent representative to the European
Union a bit like the Italian embassy to
the EU during the six months one of the
main responsibilities that I will have
will be that of chairing the horrible to
that is the committee of the permanent
representatives which are the
ambassador's of the 28 member states to
European Union the decision process in
the European Union has different letters
so first you start discussing at the
expert level in what are called the
working groups then those working groups
are giving their work to Cora pair then
Korra pair to the counselor in the
council to the European Council the
presidency of the Union means presiding
over the different counts informations
with the exception of the Foreign
Affairs Council and of European Council
that have a permanent chair one of the
main task of the presidency before you
start the beatings is to define the
priorities so to define and set up the
agenda for these for the meetings and
this is done on the basis of a number of
political orientations which are given
by the capital and then the bodies here
in Brussels working groups and corapi
are translating into reality first of
all I would like to get your agreement
on the agenda of when you check or a
pair the most difficult thing is to be
sure of interpreting in a correct way
the
indications that are coming from
different member states because you need
to reconcile the positions of the 28
countries and in order to let you have
to understand which is the point where
everybody can agree to a common position
to do this work you cannot be alone you
need to be helped by many people by all
the colleagues that are working in
deployment representation but more than
everybody else but the one who is
coordinating the preparation of Korra
pair that is the intention i am called
antichi after the Netherland diplomat
who created this group in 1975 Paloma
symantec G&T she works in close contact
with the Ambassador to help in preparing
his work negotiating with the entities
of the other member states during the
presidency the job changes because the
president is called to not to present a
national position but on the contrary to
steer the work of the Council of the
group to find a solution which is
acceptable to all we work all night long
we are always on call twenty-four-seven
I have a long experience of night
meetings and that's necessary because to
reach an agreement among 28 member
states is very difficult meanwhile
another team is working just as hard
I'm the Italian deputy permanent
representative to the European Union and
ambassador to coralville one core
everyone is the meeting of the 28th
European ambassadors in Brussels it
meets twice a week and it prepares and
approves legislation and policies on a
number of very important sectors such as
energy environment agriculture
telecommunication all sectors that
really influenced the life of the
European citizens it is coke repair one
because those areas were the first to be
tackled by the European Community the
other more political areas such as
foreign policy defense came later if
there are no comments I conclude that
the agenda is adopted during the
presidency i chair the correct one I
prepare the agenda and I find and I
contribute to finding agreements within
the group then I also share the
negotiations with the European
Parliament in order to finalize the
important pieces of legislation once
again coordination is key and for the
vice ambassador the person in charge is
called the Mertens
I'm called the Mertens after the name of
the Belgian diplomat who first share
this group in 1993 as mertens we prepare
corporal one meetings we usually gather
at the day before corporal 1 and
delegates are invited to anticipate the
positions that ambassador will express
during the presidency the chair of
mertens group is usually in charge of
defining the Corporal 1 and council
agendas and also to gather information
in order to facilitate the task of the
ambassador to reach an agreement the
biggest challenge is usually to make
sure that kiratpur one council meetings
or run smoothly are effective an
agreement is reached at the end of
course this is a very lengthy exercise
and therefore I hope that we'll be able
to see my babies from time to time all
these agreements that are reached in to
cover one and corporate two then need to
be negotiated with the other colleges
later the European Parliament and during
the presidency the role of our team is
to make sure that this continuous
dialogue is smooth and effective and
hopefully that it results in two
successful adoption of European
legislation
we will have more than 1500 meetings and
our team is responsible for organizing
all of them that means calendar
logistics interpretation and of course
working meals and there is a big
expectation on that because we are the
Italian presidency during the presidency
there is a lot of interest by the press
and of course our team deals with it for
example we help the ambassador brief the
press ahead of council meetings and we
do the same with ministers afterwards we
also do extra media monitoring and we
set up interviews draft statements
everything coordination with our
colleagues in Rome
I don't know if there is anything
exciting in being president because it's
awful lot work nah sleep nah normal life
not time for yourself that if you
consider that next presidency for Italy
could happen no sooner than 2029 then
you realize that is once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity for someone like me were
spent most of his professional life in
European institutions this is a way to
understand if you have understood enough
of European Union